[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone my name is James Reese
community developer on the crew - and
today give yourself every time a studio
is absolutely thrilled to give you a
world premiere first look at the latest
installment in the crew franchise
there's no better playground to explore
the thrill and excitement of motorsports
than america in the crew - we of the
players the challenge of dominating the
road sea and sky of a fully realized
open world USA welcome to the city that
never sleeps in this event you'll see
New York taken over by racers in a way
you never could have imagined it's not
just a city it's a playground for the
best pilots and drivers of today and
tomorrow
welcome to motivation
[Music]
there's a contest happening right now in
the new york city it's being run and
commented by life motivations number one
sponsor and event organizer
so this is where your story begins your
goal to become the greatest champion of
all motorsports
starting off women lay claim Street race
challenge street racing is at the core
of the crew DNA and one of the many
disciplines of the crew to that this
time were shifting from underground
street racing to bring you a more
accessible festive and competitive take
on the genre
you
which this race is about to get a little
spiced up how would you like to take
this party to the rooftops
now that was just a small example of the
way we've redesigned the US cities to
offer you more freedom for spontaneous
challenges in the crew to your whole
environment has been shaped and tweaked
so that you can enjoy the very best
experience whatever the vehicle or the
discipline
but before I tell you anymore I think
live sports Gus has something to tell me
and now why do this
now the second part of the competition
is a powerboat race you're piloting a DC
B m31 one of the fastest boats ever
created these little beasts are
traditionally used to race offshore and
in straight lines
we've decided it would be more fun to
have them speed up along the Hudson
River because they why not right now
we're having it pretty easy but you'll
occasionally have to deal with 10-foot
waves on actual races not to mention the
waves created by you and your
competitors
we've also been messing around with a
good old Hudson River having ramps and
boys for you to handle
and as you can see in your next
competitors the waiting for you to take
off everything is completely seamless so
anything can happen in the multi nation
at any time but for now let's stay
focused all the way up to the finish
line
we kick it up a notch for the grand
finale
Oh
we are literally taking the challenge to
new heights in this third and last part
of our New York challenge while some of
our competitors are still having fun
down there on the water
let's enjoy some new perspectives over
Central Park now that you can fly across
America the crew tube is built to allow
you to see all the way over to the
horizon
this is one of the many technical feats
our team had to achieve in order to
offer a game experience that would
perfectly fit the new vehicle types this
reasons the game's exciting potential
for exploration even more here you're
embracing the city skyline but now
imagine flying over the Rockies welding
the ground in the Grand Canyon piercing
the clouds or just admiring the city
night lights from the cockpit both
igress we're still trying to win a race
here
from the heart of New York City this was
a live extreme Theory episode one
thank you for watching and remember to
follow us on all social media
you
now let's take a look at our colossal
open world of more than two thousand
square miles it revolves around four
motorsports families street racing pro
racing off-road and freestyle each of
them has its own culture style set of
disciplines and a place to meet but the
crew too is also about freedom and
exploration time to discover what this
huge open world has to offer back in New
York City and we've joined some friends
for a free flight session in coop let me
show you what this disco edge 540 v3 has
under the hood this light plane is the
star of many air races and aerobatic
shows around the world and right here in
motor nation that's another one of the
crew to innovations not only does it
offer an incredible variety of
disciplines but each gameplay has its
specificities and unique appeal by the
way you can simply switch between ground
water and air vehicles without brand new
third wave feature this allows you to
fully enjoy all the new perspectives the
crew too has to offer using only one
button from the top of buildings that
the bustling city streets below or the
busy waterways the whole of the USA is
ready for you to explore
now you might have noticed I keep
scoring points here that's what we call
dynamic freestyle every stunt and feat
achieved anywhere in the open world will
contribute to your overall professional
game doing aerobatics tricks car and
bike stunts or just speeding up in your
boat literally anything you can show off
will get you closer to becoming a
renowned champion of motor nation now
it's time to race in the great outdoors
this is Rally Raid an off-road
discipline focus the objective here is
simple get from point A to point B as
quickly as you can by making a way to
muddy tracks rocks and vegetation and of
course the organizers that live lighted
their two cents to the challenge by
throwing in a few surprises
the buggy a1 is a perfect choice for
challenging with its bouncy suspension
unconventional looks and easy handling
after all Rally Raid is all about
enjoying total freedom to choose your
path to test the limits of your
environment and the pure fun to go
full-speed into the wild
now I'm excited to share with you how
we'll be dominating the waterways in
Jasper this will have slaloming and
jumping into swampy waters in tiny the
highly responsive boats
as you might have guessed this game
played is a bit more challenging than
the ones I've been introducing so far
the contests usually take place in a
lush and pretty unpredictable
environment and it requires high speed
mastery as well as in freestyle
abilities
sit-ins want to create things without
having the whole USA as our open world
every terrain is a perfect spot to be
disciplined with its own ecosystem road
network facilities as well as some
surprises so that's it for now I hope
you've enjoyed this versatile peak at
the unique experience will be offering
with the crew to remember in this brand
new world of non-stop competition and No
Limits exploration there's lots more for
you to discover see you again soon with
new disciplines new challenges and new
unexplored parts of motor nation don't
forget to sign up these access on the
crew game comm /bt
[Music]